anthony la nique aux jupes des filles en
rythme annuel ils ont rebâti alors le 15
juillet 1997 à 8h45 en plein ocean drive
à miami le couturier gianni versace été
assassiné de deux balles calibre 40 ce
jour là il était allé chercher le
journal tout seul vous viviez avec lui
depuis 15 ans
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas les acheter le
journal avec lui ce matin
alors je ne sais pas vraiment parce
qu'il était se réveiller très tôt il est
parti
pour acheter les journaux et
moi je me suis réveillé à cette avenue
est plus ou moins et puis
j'attendais un ami pour aller jouer au
tennis
mais
alors là ça ça andrew qu'une annan sera
retrouvé suicidé la tête explosée par
une balle du même calibre le 23 juillet
suivant dans un house boat de indian
creek on est sûr que c'était lui
l'assassin
qu'est ce que je peux dire à certains
moi je vu un garçon quand
juste après
la clôture la corsa et les garçons que
j'ai vu c'était lui
après quand je suis rentré en italie
la personne qu'ils ont trouvé dans la
baie de la baule
les additionner
identifier
ça vous a pas demandé de revenir en
amérique en vérité c'était du oui alors
là ça sert aucune annan était un
prostitué gay de 27 ans on a dit que
gianni versace et vous le connaissiez
pas du tout je vais pas de la
connaissance de celui là jusqu'à les
jours qu'ils ont sur le dit que c'était
lui ouais
j'aime l'aviez jamais vu avant moi
jamais on a dit qu'il était amoureux de
vous vous aviez une à plérin c'est pas
vrai je ne sais pas d'accord secours
n'ont finalement l' enquête a été close
sans explication du meurtre
vous savez je crois que il ya des
personnes qui devient à peu
nicolas n'est
pas uniquement le temps parce que il
avait déjà tué quatre personnes la
tueuse gianni et pied ils avaient ils
ont dit qu'ils avaient encore de tuer
trois personnes à los angeles
alors vous vous dites de toute façon qui
n'est pas vraiment d'affaires parce que
gianni et vous aviez une vie
irréprochable
vous dites que traquer tranquille ouais
pas de pas d'alcool non pas du tout pas
de cocaïne j'en ai vous dites que c'est
plutôt la soeur de gianni paroisse
reculade hier elle a dû elle a dit
acquis à tout le monde enfin les sorties
parce qu'elle était à l'hôpital à new
york et quand il a dû dire que
il promet de la coque mille dollars par
jour oui si c'est fait je tiens beaucoup
d'argent ouais voilà alors vous aviez
rencontré gianni versace
d'une quinzaine d'années à l'époque il
avait fait les costumes pour un gala à
la scala oui et quand il vous a vu au
dîner qui a succédé à cette
représentation
il est tombé fou d'amour pour vous voici
une espèce de ses seins c'est ce qui m'a
dit oui
c'est il a eu un coup de foudre pour
vous je ne suis pas allé
je crois qu'il avait
trouver quelqu'un qui
il était l'image de la bouteille
classique un temps je sais pas mais moi
j'étais trop jeune oui vous vous aviez
24 ans lui 37 voilà et voilà ensuite
c'était une espèce de conte de fées une
une vraie romance gay et un josé même
déclaré vous avez annoncé votre amour
entre le premier couturier
dans les monts qui a fait la décoration
troisième en mai mais ils étaient
homosexuels
qui l'a fait non comme quoi du tout
vous avez fait ensemble un article dans
un magazine gay us qui savaient dès
advocate
cet article dandy advocate c'était un
petit peu là la consécration médiatique
de votre de votre union mais la famille
versace n'acceptez pas du tout que vous
viviez ensemble et c'est un peu bizarre
parce que c'est la famille vers sortie
n'acceptez pas à juba copé parce que et
s'est mariée avec le garçon qui était
avant des années avant moi c'était les
affiliations des jeunes
dont un peu bizarre l'histoire mais en
tous les cas d'aidé la mort de gianni
versace vous avez été vous avez été
chassés quoi
delaborde lui avec ma famille et moi je
pu contacter ça a commencé le matin du
meurtre puisque vous êtes interdit de
d'ambulances on vous interdit
d'accompagner le corps de gianni versace
à l'hôpital et on vous emmène dans un
commissariat pour pour témoigner et vous
avez passé toute la journée à rennes
jusqu'à deux heures le soir
rappliquer
du coup la cause ça parce que j'ai
jamais d'aller jouer au tennis au foie
avec l'air conditionné
c'est habile
et par devoir rien de tout nous dit si
ç'avait été une femme
une femme mariée avec gianni versace on
l'aurait pas emmener au poste on
l'aurait d'abord les ciels l hôpital
quoi bien sûr oui je crois que c'est
n'importe quoi c'est vrai alors pas le
droit d'aller à l'hôpital pas le droit
de l'habiller pas le droit de choisir
l'endroit où ses cendres seront seront
enterrés et tout ça malgré une vie de 15
ans ensemble exactement 24 heures sur 24
parce que c'était difficile parce que
après quinze ans tu penses que tu as des
trois oui avec la personne que tu as
aimé pour longtemps
mais là dans un minus et cassé des tout
c'est tout je t'aime
reste ouais vous avez été écarté de
l'héritage
c'est vrai qu'à un moment gianni versace
vous avez proposé 20% des actions de sa
société où les aviez refusé et là vous
avez été complètement rayé de l'héritage
de versace exactement
j'avais obtenu quoi une rente jusqu'en
2007 c'est ça une rente de 25000 euros
par mois jusqu'en 2007 lui il faut lever
les taxes qui sont tus de la moitié
vous aviez aussi la jouissance des
maisons de gianni versace mais vous avez
déclaré que pour vous c'était difficile
d'aller dans des maisons où il était
plus là finalement c'était oui d'abord
vie c'était très difficile parce que
avec tous les objets tous les choses qui
ont acheté ensemble la vie inconnue ça
fait ça fait du mal à les voir et puis
après parce que il n'y avait vraiment
pas
l'exigence de rester là bas avec la
famille qui m'a refusé complètement de
jeudi vous partiriez si ce à dire que
vous avez travaillé encore quelques mois
chez versace où il divise entre voilà
vous êtes parti avec vos indemnités à
janvier je terminais la collection que
j'avais commencé je suis portée ou dit
la façon dont il traitait les robes
visite imiter les robes par terre il n'y
avait pas de respect comme du temps des
coûts non
parce que johnny il a il avait une un
respect pour le travail d'une personne
qui travaillait pour lui donc les robes
même les robes et les touches est pas
tellement lui mais il voulait pas que
les touches et le vôtre il y avait des
personnes qui les prenaient leur portée
et jean m à part faire taire parce que
c'était moi y est donc
alors johnny fait de ses nièces allègre
à la l'héritière principal de sa fortune
à 50% des parts via n'est pas capable
aujourd'hui de gérer la faire parce que
l'anorexie qu'elle est malade exactement
elle est tombée malade juste deux mois
après
celle à vraiment se faire là la petite
c'est un frère dont il était très proche
de ses nièces il a appelé ma princesse
était très proche d'elle et
malheureusement aujourd'hui elle n'est
pas en mesure de lui succéder donc c'est
sa soeur donne at elle acquis qui
s'occupe des affaires de versace moins
d'un ménage
s'ils avaient le pacs en italie commis
en france les choses auraient été
différentes poro oui oui ça reste un
rêve ça n'existe pas en italie non
rassurez vous avez des politiciens en
italie qui sont quand même
but idiot mais vous avez beauty l'yonne
celui que ses bouteilles auraient
déclaré que l'homosexualité est un péché
vous avez fini qui vient du parti ex
fasciste disons exactement il a déclaré
que
l'homosexuel ip par trade à l'école pour
un seigneur dans l'école parce que c'est
le problème c'est avec l'argent qu'on
semble vraiment rien que ça voilà un
pays où il n'ya pas le pacs ou la voilà
le résultat quoi et puis est un pays où
la lys a pu sauver l'église et le port
voilà c'est tout parce que ça comprend
pas est ce qu'il ya des pride en italie
il faut les grilles progresser et
ridicule parce que tous les x il faut
voir y effectuer les mecs qui vont avec
les plumes elle est reconnue mais si
jamais tout sera à refaire ce s'est
passé à l'anomie socialité sur un nom
aujourd'hui ça va mieux donc ça y est
vous commencez à vous vous reportage je
retrouvais ma la sérénité de l'annoncé à
vivre un peu plus tard qui y
penser quand même souvent adjani dans la
journée ça vous obsède où il est il est
présent tout l'avis de tous les temps
quand il est là avec moi
j'ai des moments qui sont un peu tristes
de moment qui
je pense
la vie qu'on a passé ensemble
mais ça va mieux
s'il n'avait pas été assassiné vous
seriez rester encore longtemps sans
jouer c'est
dans l'émoi des marsois devient
22 ans
non ça fait longtemps
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux